(voice over loudspeaker)
- Next to the product placement
that Subway engages in overseas.
Particularly in Korean dramas
where every plot point
seems to occur at a Subway.
Here is two characters
having a meeting at one.
Here is a group of men
celebrating the fact
their friend's just woke up from a coma.
- I'm going to South Korea,
let's look into this.
- [John] Subway's done
a significant amount
of product placement.
I'm talking of course about
Korean sandwich dramas.
- Subway in South Korea.
I did not come to Seoul, South Korea
to talk about Subway sandwiches.
I am here for a different story,
one that really focuses on this city
that is 40 kilometers
from the border with North Korea.
But I was in the Istanbul airport
on a layover on my way to South Korea
and I watched that John Oliver clip
and started to go down a rabbit hole.
(upbeat music)
Subway shows up a lot in Korean dramas.
Not just like one or two,
but like five, 10, 15,
almost 20 different shows
have product placement
from Subway sandwiches.
The American fast food chain
that is apparently the largest
fast food chain in the
world by store locations.
What?
What is going on here?
Subway is not cool, it is not good,
and yet K-dramas are full of Subway.
We gotta get to the bottom of this.
Is there something special
about Korean Subway?
Like is it different?
Am I missing something?
Is there something better
about Korean Subway
versus American Subway?
Because if there is I
want to know about it.
So first, let's settle that.
I'll do mozzarella, hot chili,
salt and pepper.
Okay, after that very scientific study
which by the way was a
little bit scientific
because I did choose the specialty items
that only exist in Korea
and not in America,
and I chose something that had beef in it
which is a thing that
Korea does really well.
So I tried to give South Korea
the best chance of being differentiated,
and the result is that it
is kind of better, kind of.
- Eat fresh.
Eat fresh.
- That's my man.
- But not really.
It's like still just microwaves
and like mass produced
industrial ingredients
prepared in front of you.
They kind of taste old and stale,
kind of delicious at the same time.
I don't know.
But the thing I noticed at this location
and several others that I've visited
in my short time here in Seoul
is that these subways
look and feel different.
Cleaner, more sleek, well lit.
So yeah, I guess you could say
that Subway sandwiches taste better
when you're eating them here
instead of here.
Okay, this is not what
this video is about.
It's not about whether or not
Korean Subway is better
than American Subway,
you can decide that.
I'm interested in how Subway sandwiches
has taken over Korean dramas.
There is an explanation for this.
I talked to an expert in this topic
who's like the guy to explain it.
He's a communications and media professor
at one of the best universities in Korea,
and he has thoughts on this.
But first, I have to do the thing
that allows me to make these videos
which is tell you about the
sponsor of today's video.
So let's go back to Washington
DC for a few moments
and thank today's sponsor.
Here we are back in Washington DC
doing an ad read.
But unlike Subway in K-dramas,
I am actually putting a break
between the video and this ad read.
That's the difference, all
media has to make money somehow,
I just am doing it
by putting a wall between
the story and the ad.
So thank you NordVPN for
sponsoring today's video.
A VPN is a tool that I use pretty often,
especially lately as I've been traveling.
Being in Korea, my
computer's been freaking out
as I try to log into things.
And so to solve that,
I log onto NordVPN and I
connect to the internet
via the United States.
And this isn't some
like coding nerd thing,
this is like press one button
and you're now connected
via the United States,
and now I can log onto Gmail,
and Gmail is just fine with it
and no one freaks out, and we're good.
A VPN also allows you to watch stuff
that like isn't maybe
available in your country,
but you just connect via the UK
and suddenly you're
watching like Netflix UK.
It's pretty cool.
NordVPN is also expanding
to become a threat protection tool.
It's a tool that allows you
to block malicious trackers, malware,
and when you're like sitting
on public wifi in a cafe,
and you're not super secure,
it totally gives you a buffer of security
that to me gives me a
little peace of mind.
And right now they're having a 30 day
money back guarantee if you sign up.
So really, you have nothing to lose.
You can try this out and see if it works.
There is a link in my description,
it's NordVPN.com/JohnnyHarris.
When you click that link it
helps support this channel
so go do us both a favor, click the link,
and you also will get
in on an exclusive deal.
Four months of free NordVPN
to try it out for four months.
Thank you NordVPN for
supporting this channel,
back to Korea to figure
out what's going on
with K-drama and Subway.
You know, maybe I should have done that ad
as a product placement.
No, I wouldn't do that,
you probably would be very angry if I did,
like slipped it into this video.
- Subway cannot stand for that,
and frankly Rick, I'm surprised you did.
- Instead, there was an ad break,
there was a little commercial,
and now we're back to the show.
That is a very normal model
for a lot of media around the world,
but not in Korea.
Turns out that South Korea has
a very different culture
surrounding advertising and media.
And by very different I mean
they haven't ever allowed
there to be commercial breaks.
No commercials.
You're watching a TV
show on the television,
which most of you don't do anymore,
but like forever that's the way it's been
and then there's a commercial break.
Like that's a very normal thing,
we're all very used to it.
In South Korea that has not been allowed.
It's been against the law,
it's been completely regulated against.
(speaking in Korean)
In Korea they're obsessed with this idea
of viewership rights.
It's a very aggressive set of regulations
that don't let advertisers
put commercials in shows.
Spoiler alert, that's slightly changing.
But for years, that has
always been the case.
(speaking in Korean)
Okay, but then a few
things start to happen.
These broadcasters, these TV channels
really started to struggle
because people were moving away from TV.
And this really threatened
the shows that were being made
because now they wouldn't have a budget.
Korean dramas were
starting to see popularity
and get viewers all over the world.
The Korean government saw an opportunity
to change their advertising rules
to let advertisers put
Korean goods and products
into the shows.
To advertise, but like
as a part of the story,
not like in a commercial that's like
in the middle of the show,
but like to bake in a product to the story
which is called product placement.
So in 2010, they started
to ease these restrictions,
and people go nuts.
And it got really cringey really fast.
(speaking in Korean)
(yelling)
Yeah, it was pretty bad.
Every product placement is a gamble.
If you make it too
obvious, too on the nose
then it can actually create
a negative association with your brand,
and there's backlash.
But what it did was it put more money
into these shows, bigger budgets,
and the shows got better and better
and the audiences around the world grew,
and the product placement got
more and more sophisticated.
- It's just an interesting
system in Korea,
where rather than drama companies
approaching advertisers,
it's advertisers who
approach drama companies.
- I mean there's a lot of money in this.
(speaking in Korean)
Do a couple of those,
and you're making some pretty good cash
to make your show better.
At first it was Korean and Chinese brands,
which got a lot of scrutiny,
people kind of hated it.
(speaking in Korean)
And then a few years ago,
Subway the sandwich maker
decided that they wanted in on this.
(speaking in Korean)
(upbeat music)
One thing I love about this city so far
is that there are just
little nooks and crannies.
I'm in the middle of the city,
and there's this little
peaceful like garden space.
Look at this,
this is like right in front of Starbucks.
Subway's strategy was very bold.
They decided they wanted
to own this space.
They poured tons and tons of money
into product placement into K-dramas,
as well as increasing
celebrity endorsements
which is another thing that has
a lot of marketing power in South Korea.
They started to go nuts.
They're like it's time
for a brand refresh.
Yeah we know we're getting a lot of flack
for our tuna and our bread
and all of this in other countries,
but here in South Korea,
it's a clean slate.
We're gonna establish
a new brand perception
through K-dramas and celebrities.
And that is exactly what they did.
(speaking in Korean)
The thing about Subway
that makes sense here
is that like Subway is a product,
but it's also a place.
And every show needs a set,
it needs a place for things to happen.
It could be a nameless cafe,
or a random restaurant,
or it could be a Subway sandwiches.
And especially because
the regulation made it
so that you couldn't have the actors
overtly be like you should buy Subway.
You can like show the space,
you can show the brand,
you can show them like eating it,
but you can't have them like overtly
tell people to buy things
which is just fine for Subway.
Because now they can integrate their store
and their food into these stories.
- Excessive number of visits
to locations like Subway
can be quite jarring.
At a certain point they can ruin the mood
or they can become comical
because nobody actually wants
to eat at Subway that often.
- Sometimes it's just a matter of like
people sitting around
having a conversation
while they have like beautifully
packaged Subway sandwiches
having the logo faced towards the camera.
But with time it started to become
more and more intertwined
with the actually storyline.
Like this show about a ghost
who can't eat anything
because he's a ghost,
but then this man hands
him a subway sandwich
and suddenly he can eat,
and he's really happy and excited
because he was so hungry.
I'm not sure how that makes sense
in the context of the story,
or like the rules of
this like ghost world,
but it made sense for Subway's bottom line
and the budget of this production.
- And the Emmy goes to Subway.
(applause)
- Some of these are so on the nose
where like the plot point itself
is about how delicious the sandwich looks.
Like look at her just like
staring at that sandwich
and she's just like I want that
and suddenly I'm looking at this
and I'm like I want it too.
Like maybe I need to go back to Subway
and get another sandwich.
Here's a man who's dying,
they're trying to revive
him with a defibrillator,
and he goes into a dream state.
He's on the fringe of death
and like his last memory
is like remembering this date he went on
to a Subway sandwiches.
He feeds her the sandwich
and the soft drink
all with the logo perfectly
placed to face the camera,
I mean it's so good.
Oh and guess what, it's
absolutely working.
One Subway executive here in Korea
told the New York Times
that it is night and day
the difference between
the before and the after
of product placement.
Oh and it's not just for swooning Koreans
into loving Subway.
Remember how K-dramas are becoming
really popular in the United States?
Showing these slick subway shops
and delicious looking sandwiches
to an American audience via Korean dramas,
which are exploding in the states,
is this bizarre round
trip of brand awareness,
and to be honest, it's kind of brilliant.
Like it's, I don't know,
I've only been thinking about this
for like 36 hours, but like
it's kind of working on me too.
Like I'm having some renewed interest
in like wait, is Subway cool?
- Subway I love you.
- It's a very different thing
than the association I have,
and that's what branding is,
it's this mental tug of war.
(speaking in Korean)
This is just like branding 101,
and Subway is doing a damn good job at it
through Korean dramas.
Oh, and it's not just
Subway that's classier,
Dunkin Donuts is also
super nice in South Korea.
I've never seen a Dunkin Donuts
that looks anything other
than a dingy, gross place,
but the Dunkin Donuts
here looks really nice.
I'm gonna go get a donut.
(speaking in Korean)
It's been really fascinating for me to see
all of these American
brands here in South Korea
who have been able to like start afresh
in this new market.
To basically build the brand
that they wish they would have
back in the United States.
(speaking in Korean)
So yeah it's working for Subway,
but they've also pushed
it a little bit too far.
There are moments in
some of these K-dramas
where a guy just like gives
someone else a Subway sandwich.
It has nothing to do with the story.
It's like okay.
- Product placement
for brand new products,
especially high tech products
that Koreans aren't using yet.
Like characters who in the drama
might not actually have the finances
to invest in that kind of gadget.
Those are particularly
annoying to me personally.
When you have these lines
about how much a
character loves the coffee
or wants the coffee,
it's like this is instant coffee people,
it's not that amazing.
- Overall, Subway has come out on top.
They've been able to walk the line
kind of balancing between
overt product placement
that gives them a lot of screen time
while also trying to
make it somewhat natural,
like not too forced and cringey
and like off the plot.
And they're getting
better and better at this,
at like integrating it into the story
so that it's not so awkward.
And perhaps most brilliantly
they've done a good job
at like kind of making fun of themselves
for like this sort of trope
of over product placement.
In this little web series
they did on YouTube
which is like a little drama,
but it was produced by
Subway all about Subway.
Like the entire plot
takes place in a Subway
about a Subway employee,
and there's like a love
story with this girl,
and it has to do with like
the plant based sandwich
and like the steak and cheese sandwich.
John Oliver kind of made this sound
like this was a really serious thing,
but this was totally
tongue in cheek satire.
Subway knows that this trope
is like kind of ridiculous
and they're poking fun at themselves.
Showing some self-awareness
that like definitely disarms any critics.
But then also, people have told me
that this show is actually
like kind of good.
Like they can see themselves watching
all of the episodes.
It has millions of views.
Like this is funny satire
mixed with like real storytelling,
and Subway is at the center of it,
like come on.
Who is doing this?
Who is in charge of this?
They're doing a great job.
Congratulations marketing people
who are in charge of this, it's working.
(speaking in Korean)
So product placement in K-dramas
is only gonna get more sophisticated,
more a part of the story,
and more ubiquitous.
(speaking in Korean)
It's such a strange interesting cycle,
but it's happening, there's no going back.
I did not come to South Korea
to talk about Subway sandwiches.
Alas I am here for a different story
that I have been reporting on while here
up at the border with North Korea
learning a lot about the realities
of the situation here
in the Korean Peninsula.
Spoiler alert, it's quite a bit different
than what we hear on the news in the west,
so stay tuned for that.
Watch yourself some K-dramas,
get yourself some Subway
and you will officially
be on the front lines
of this weird disruptive strange time
of globalized media and
advertising and food.
What is happening?
Life is weird, okay bye.
(speaking in Korean)
One of my favorite things
about the city so far
is the little strips of light
that are red when you can't walk,
and green when you can.
It's so cool.